malee more The Washington Post in your
book you write the deeper I dug into the
war the angry I'd be angrier I became
and how the politicians and the military
had duped the media and the public you
feel that all through the whole works
print roof very much of it the military
really manipulated the media in this war
I mean they had a leash around our neck
they controlled everything we saw and
did and in the ground war they
controlled much of what we wrote because
they had the right to censor what was in
our copy as it came off the battlefield
give us an example or maybe the the the
biggest example you can remember where
you were with we couldn't write what you
want to write well they're part of the
problem was getting out to the field
from day one out there when we landed in
in Saudi Arabia was getting out to see
what was really going on the military
totally controlled where you could go in
the desert it wasn't as though you could
jump in your jeep and drive around and
go out to a command post on your own you
were really at their mercy
and I was actually more fortunate than
most of the reporters I had covered the
military for five years knew many of the
commanders and the public affairs
officials and got around some of the
restrictions but during the ground war
there were many of my colleagues that
just had absolutely horrendous
experiences the USA Today reporter for
instance spent weeks living with his
unit out in the desert and then during
the ground war was writing furiously
every day of the four to five day ground
war and thought that his copy was
getting back to doc Ron and at the end
of the war he went back to the Army
Headquarters and they handed him to his
stack of stories and said here you can
take them back when you go now my
situation I was on the battlefield with
Lieutenant General Walt boomer who was
commander of the Marine Corp about four
days before the ground war he sent me a
fax from the front line saying I'd like
to invite you to come watch the war with
me and I thought this was probably about
the most extraordinary invitation
anybody could get he invited five other
reporters all of whom turned him down
because they didn't want to spend the
war in some generals command post they
wanted to be out on the front lines
well this general of course turned out
to be somewhat of
kamikaze general in a few hours after
the war began leaped into a mobile
convoy with his headquarters staff threw
me in a chevy blazer with his satellite
and we took off for the war front and so
i had this extraordinary window on the
war and the frustrating thing about it
though and one of the main reasons that
I will wrote a woman at war was so
little of what I saw in wrote ever made
it off the battlefield and got back to
the Washington Post because the war
moved so fast the communications were so
terrible there were just you know
problem after problem out on the
battlefield of actually filing your
stories did you get that picture this
picture was taken by Larry downing he
was on one of the media pools and was
just one day we were standing out
talking to some troops with the 24th
Infantry Division and he was snapping
pictures of us about the picture in the
background this this is one of the
troops out in the desert take taken
during a sunrise as the troops are
moving across the desert and this is not
your John Wayne Western Desert this is a
desert where there's not so much as a
cactus or a tree out there it's just a
wide flat open desert we're in the
middle of nineteen ninety-three remind
us when all this happened and what time
period were you over there I went in
August of 1991 just a few days after the
invasion of Kuwait and as people may
recall it was very different couple
reporters to get into Saudi Arabia even
in the best of times the Saudis don't
let reporters in and Secretary of
Defense Dick Cheney went on a mission to
try to get these Arab countries to allow
the US military to put aircraft and in
on their soil and ships in their ports
and much like when the president travels
he takes the Pentagon press corps with
him when he travels and I went with him
and discovered the day before I got on
the plane that I had a visa to stay in
Saudi Arabia 30 days not just the four
days of the Cheney trip so I got off the
plane and didn't come back to the US at
the end of his trip how did you go about
writing the book what's in it for
somebody that has no idea what they're
about to read well I think that this
book hopefully gives people a window on
the war that they didn't see I came back
from the war and it seemed to me that
the American people believed that this
was a very quick and
it was antiseptic it was surgical
you saw the missiles coming through the
front doors of the warehouses hitting
everything just perfectly and the war I
saw was nothing like that
the ground war that I saw was chaotic
there were miscalculations there were
mistakes there was one day with general
boomer during the toughest day of
fighting couldn't communicate all day
with one of his senior commanders
because of communications problems there
were friendly fire incidents it's
amazing there weren't even more than
those we all knew about at the time and
heard about after the war and I want
news to give people in a woman at war a
view of the nitty-gritty side of the war
that people didn't see on TV and they
didn't see in the newspapers because at
the time we couldn't get a lot of this
out and I also wanted to give people
kind of a behind-the-scenes view of what
goes on in war I mean no reporter that I
know of has ever had the kind of access
that I was lucky enough to have with
this general I mean I was going through
the course of the four-day ground war
with him living in his tent with his
chief operations officer listening to
his conversations back to Riyadh with
general Schwarzkopf just a view that I
was so fortunate to see I thought it
would be a shame to lose it the only
thing that I think may have been a
sequence is the first chapter you start
off with the chapter that on page 12 we
learned that you slept in the same tent
with the general and that was on
February the 25th 1991 how come you let
another well the book is an adventure
story even if you don't care anything
about the Persian Gulf War that was two
years ago say you don't care anything
about it
this is a venture story about the human
side of war and the fears the anxieties
what's going on in the commander's head
what's going on and the journalists head
what's going on in the minds of these
young men who think they're gonna die
when they cross the border and I begin
the book with a flashback to the first
night that I'm on the battlefield and we
are going through the minefields it's
pitch dark the oil wells are burning
sending up these vast purple dark clouds
of smoke over the entire battlefield and
we end up trapped in a minefield we're
listening to the radios and we're
listening to the men on the radio saying
you know there are armed Iraqis on your
left machine guns on your right we were
surrounded by Iraqis didn't know
whether they were going to surrender to
us or try to take us prisoner or I start
shooting at us
so for four hours were immobilized in
the darkness and the middle of this
minefield and the commander the Marine
courses forces is commanding the war
from this extraordinary situation and I
thought that it would provide a good
opener to hook people on the type of
scenes they would be seeing in the book
as it went along did has anybody in your
tour asked you about sleeping the tent
with the gentleman oh everyone of course
now sleeping was a little bit of a
misnomer because of course you're in the
middle of a war and in fact one night as
we're sitting there we hear artillery
the Americans firing over us at the
Iraqis in front of us the Iraqis firing
over us at the Americans behind us and
we're sitting there saying you know God
don't let these shells fall short and
land on us all night long general boomer
and his operations chief colonel bill
Steve were working the radios there were
constant foul-ups on the battlefield
there were Allied troops crossing into
other Allied troops territory so you
they were constantly trying to untangle
these traffic jams on the battlefield so
you wouldn't have these friendly fire
incidents there was one night the last
night obsessively of the war when the
Marines had surrounded Kuwait City and
we're preparing for the Arab forces to
go in and all day long general
Schwarzkopf had been telling general
boomer you know don't let those Marines
in Kuwait City we want the Arab forces
going in first and tomorrow morning at
dawn the Army Special Forces teams are
going to come in and essentially land at
the US Embassy raised the American flag
well during the course of the night some
Marines snuck into Kuwait City captured
the embassy and put up the American flag
and Schwarzkopf was livid boomer was
getting these calls from Riyadh
screaming at him for letting the Marines
in the city and boomer would you know
hang up this field telephone and just
kind of chuckle and say well I have to
admit I'm pretty proud of him for doing
it I can't get mad at him despite how
angry Schwarzkopf was at him what was
the relationship between Walter boomer
and the Marine general and general
Schwarzkopf the relationship between the
commanders during the war was quite good
I mean they were all in this together
however Schwarzkopf had a very different
side to him
people saw in the press conference view
of general Schwartzkopf I mean he would
chew out a general as though he were a
lance carpel he was an absolute tyrant
to work for and there were several cases
during the ground war when he became
rather angry at general boomer one was
the fact that boomer had me out there
covering the war with him the first day
of the war there was a news blackout for
several hours we were filing our stories
boomer came to the place where I was
working in his command post one hour
after the war started to give me the
official quotes for the story get the
story out within two hours after the
ground war actually started I filed four
or five stories and none of them went
anywhere except to general Schwarzkopf
some deaths because he wanted to see
what the tenor of the stories were
before he allowed them to be released
and at one point I described an a woman
at war general boomer comes into his
operation center where I was being
briefed on the battles that were going
on and says I've been muzzled as far as
coffee'd calling and said you know I
don't want to see my generals being
quoted in these stories on the war this
early you know keep your name out of
these stories there was another incident
the night that the Marines had
surrounded Kuwait City general boomer
got a call on the radio from general
Schwarzkopf saying what are all these
reporters doing in Kuwait City as you
know your viewers may recall Dan Rather
was there and other reporters it snuck
into Kuwait City to be there for the
liberation and for Scott was furious and
boomer said well they're there because I
told my men to let them in he said I
thought it was in the best interest of
our relationship with the media to let
them be there to cover the liberation of
Kuwait City but one of the most
extraordinary incidents and I didn't
learn about this in fact until after the
war in my research for a woman at war
was that general Schwarzkopf one day
during one of the cuts cut attacks is
down sleeping on his cot in the basement
of the headquarters in Riyadh he gets
out he hates these Scott attacks and
these Scud warnings you know he thinks
this guys they're not gonna hit the
building where he is he gets up he flips
on CNN and he sees a tape of a slam
missile which it's the first time this
missile has ever been used in real
combat and it was a picture-perfect hit
and there had been a news pull
out on one of the Navy ships and that
they caught this on film and put it out
on the pool reports for all the
television stations to use and smart
scoffs saw this and was absolutely livid
he called the commander of the joint
information Bureau the Public Affairs
Office in Dhahran the guy was this
Colonel bill movi was in the basement of
the hotel in the middle of his honest
gut attack in his pool chemical gear
with shorts cloth screaming at him
saying you know pack your bags and be in
Riyadh tomorrow morning Schwarzkopf was
just absolutely furious this Colonel
thought he'd been fired in fact it took
the intervention of Dick Cheney and
colon Powell to calm Swartz cop down on
this and he later learned the reasons
for its cost was so angry is that he had
wanted to use that film in his own press
conference the next afternoon and had
been scooped by his own public affairs
people in his mind what did you think of
the way you noticed I noted a footnote
you've got in the back that you'd say
that general Schwarzkopf was not
available to you after this war was over
how come right he had an agreement with
his publishing company that he would not
talk to any other reporters or authors
for their books because the contract he
had on his book so it impedes somewhat
what we could do to get his side of some
of these stories because he was refusing
to talk to us would you think of that
well I can see you know he's publishing
company paid a lot of money for his book
and they I'm sure didn't want him giving
all the good stuff away before it
appeared in the book but the constraints
were so severe that even if you went to
a speech that general Schwarzkopf was
giving you couldn't take care of tape
recorder to record any of it I mean they
wanted all of this in his memoirs when
they came out but it made it very
difficult for those of us who wanted to
be very historically accurate on
everything that we were putting in our
books and we took you know and to make
up for it you just talked to as many
people around him as you could what do
you think the idea of for that matter
you reporter for a newspaper making
money off a book after war but a general
who was a public servant doing this kind
of thing afterwards anything wrong with
that I don't think so he was retired
from the military there was a lot of
controversy
see not about the money he made from the
book but the money he was making from
speaking engagements you know there were
incidents I was told of someone who
wanted him to be a speaker in Brussels
and Schwarzkopf didn't want to do it for
any less than $60,000 and this
organization couldn't pay that kind of
money so there were a lot of people in
the military that didn't think what he
was doing was right frankly I think
probably a lot of it was jealousy I mean
anybody would like to find fame and
fortune like he did and very few of them
did but it certainly raised quite a few
questions he couldn't have done it had
he still been in uniform but because he
was retired he can do it we want to ask
you that first and I don't want to over
do this sleeping in the same tent with
the general thing but I do want to ask
you about that
did your publisher say to you you've got
to put that up front in order to get
people's attention not really it was
clear to me that it was interesting that
this reporter was inside this generals
tent listening to everything that was
going on at the time there's another
aide in there with you right sure
there's a carnival Steve the operations
chief and as I said the tent was more a
shelter from these horrendous sandstorms
to cold the rain everything else as
opposed to a place to sleep I mean the
most you were doing was taking off your
flak jacket when you went in there but
the first night I was there I was
extraordinarily uncomfortable because
the entire time I was in Saudi Arabia
every time I went out to the field I
made a point of not letting them treat
me differently because I was a reporter
or because I was a woman you know their
tendency was always to give you the best
tent to give you a cot when nobody else
had a cot and I always said no I'll
sleep where the troops sleep I'll eat
what they eat so the night the first
night we're on the road the wagon master
of boomers convoy stands up and says
well men you're gonna have to sleep
under your Jeeps
you didn't bring tents and he looks at
me and it says well man we really can't
make you sleep under the Jeep you know
we're gonna have you in general boomer
and Colonel Steve dead and my first
inclination was no no no put me out
there with the troops you know I don't
want this special treatment then a split
second later I thought you know you're
crazy this is an extraordinary window
nobody gets this kind of access to a
commanding general while he's fighting
the war but at the same time the first
night is they enter the tent I think oh
my god
what am I going to talk to these guys
about they have the lives of 40,000 men
and women on their shoulders and I
didn't want to do anything to disrupt
them from their job or to distract them
from their job but the first night was
very extraordinary because general
boomer opened up and it was just this
floodgate of emotion talking about his
fears and anxieties over the past months
I mean things that he couldn't even talk
about to his commanders because he
didn't want this sense of fear and
anxiety to rub off on them and it was
just it was you were getting inside his
head
the grounders the ground rules then
because the war was still going on and
no one knew how quickly the war would
move he of course could read all my copy
before it went out but I had been
covering the situation long enough and
had been covering the military long
enough where you develop a sixth sense
of what should be in the story and what
should not be in the story I mean unlike
the American public who thinks reporters
are about as sleazy as politicians and
used-car salesmen we did impose a lot of
self-censorship
on what we were doing and that night he
was telling me the war playing very
explicit details of the war plan for the
next day and I could not report that
ahead of time in other words you
couldn't report when everybody kept
hearing future operations but that's
something I knew I mean he didn't even
really need to verbalize that but that
was really the only ground rules and I
of course during the ground war you're
in the middle of the war and the
newspaper is most interested in what's
going on now at that point they're not
real interested in this generals
ruminations of his personal feelings and
that sort of thing I did do very
in-depth stories on that after the war
was over
how did you how did you capture that
when you're there in your sleeping bag
in the middle of this tent in the middle
of the night how do you get it the
quotes accurately I had a tape recorder
with me and also had a notebook I'm
scribbling furiously but much of the war
I'm what ended up being very beneficial
for the book is I had a little tape
recorder with me for example the night
that we're trapped in the mine field
it's pitch black you can't see you too
right
anywhere I just turned on the tape
recorder and in doing the research for
the book I just listened to hours and
hours and hours of these tapes and could
reconstruct entire conversations for
Batum now the other thing that was
extraordinarily helpful and doing the
research for a woman at war with cinema
boomer did something that I think
probably has never been done before in
every one of his war planning meetings
which he had every morning he had a
staff meeting from August through April
past the end of the war he had a court
stenographer in his staff meeting that
recorded word-for-word
everything that was said and after the
war I got these tapes they were on 12
computer discs it was just a phenomenal
amount of information and I spent weeks
doing nothing but reading all of these
war meetings and that helped you get
inside the head of these guys too and
some of them were very extraordinary
they were candid there was one war
planning meeting in November when
general boomer called in all of his
generals and they were trying to decide
how they were going to attack into
Kuwait and there was a big debate on
should there be an amphibious attack and
several of the generals are saying there
well if we don't have an amphibious
attack we're out of a job because
Congress is going to say why do we need
a Marine Corps and I thought that was
just an extraordinary insight on the
politics of how some of these decisions
were made now in the end the decision
was made not to do an amphibious attack
because it would be considered too
dangerous too many people would lose
their lives Sentinel sports cars really
didn't want to do and if they be
attacked and in the end general boomer
had wanted to do one not so much for the
politics but because he felt he was
gonna need those 17,000 troops who were
offshore because he was going against
incredible odds in Iraq and was afraid
that he would there were no reserve
units he was pushing all of his men
through those minefields and onto the
battlefield and had something happened
he had no reserve to come up behind them
and fill in if they were all slaughtered
where's general boomer today
he was Assistant Commandant of the
Marine Corps the number two man in the
Marine Corps you mentioned in the book
that when he got back to Washington you
had a number of dinners with him to talk
about what went on over there in the war
has he seen this book he has and and the
notation to the dinners were the last
night the last day I was out there I
left
and of course I was thanking general
boomer for this fantastic window on the
war and I said you know we'd been eating
MREs and peanut butter for three or four
days and meals ready to eat these are
the prepackaged military meals that
taste kind of like styrofoam and
everybody's sick and they're gagging and
coughing and as I leave in his command
post I said you know you come to
Washington I'll buy you dinner at the
restaurant of your choice well as it
turned out in the research for this book
I spent hours and hours not only
interviewing general boomer but many of
his other generals and the other group
of characters in a woman at war is
Lieutenant William Delaney who was on
one of the very first tanks that went in
to Kuwait and these young men spent just
dozens and dozens of hours recounting
from me minute by minute their feelings
their emotions as they were going
through the battlefield and of course
this is a situation where you couldn't
interview these young men during the war
they were inside your tanks and I was on
a different area of the battlefield
anyway but the cooperation I got from
these people was very extraordinary and
Lieutenant Delaney instead of keeping a
journal out there because he was afraid
that all of his men would you know sneak
into his corner the tank and read his
journal wrote these extraordinary
letters back to his father chronicling
his fears and anxieties as he went
through the war I mean in one letter he
went so far as to tell his father where
he wanted to be buried he wanted to be
buried at Arlington Cemetery in a very
simple ceremony who his father should
give away his possessions to I mean
these were sort of not the macho let's
go kill Saddam Hussein men that you saw
on TV a lot of times in the interviews
and the quick sound bites many of them
thought they would never come out of
this alive tell us more about the
William Delaney scenario his father
lives where his father lives in
Montgomery County Maryland right here in
the Washington DC area it was
interesting he was raised as he
described himself a man of privilege he
went to st. Albans and an elite boys
school and he chose to join the military
the young the young bill Delaney now his
father was very opposed to his son
joining the military
his father was against this war
infrequently
his sign that he was against the war
which upset the son getting these
letters but lieutenant Delaney made the
point to his father in some of the
letters that the US military is a bit
unfair he was a man of privilege and he
chose to join the military he made the
point that most of the men working for
them for under him had no choice they
came from the south they came from the
ghettos their choice was you know
working in a fast-food joint or working
at a gas station or going in the
military and he thought that this was
very unfair that the military should
draw more from all strata of society in
his fear was that if these young men
went out there and got killed they'd be
remembered by no one but their families
the father lives here in the western
suburbs the first term so letters ended
up in the Washington Post right what
happened is that the father's after he
started receiving these extraordinary
letters and I mean they're just
beautifully written I quote it leans for
many of them and a woman at war and his
father was just moved to tears by many
of these letters and he sent them to
Mary mcgrory the columnist at the
Washington Post and she thought they
were extraordinary and she brought them
over to the National desk and gave them
to the military reporters who were here
and a story was written in The
Washington Post style session quoting
from some of these letters and on my
computer out in Saudi Arabia I can
electronically call up the Washington
Post and saw these and said you know
I've got to find this kid and as soon as
the war was over went on a search and in
fact found him his commander dragged him
off a barge where he was covered with
grease and grime hadn't had a shower in
three months they were bringing their
tanks back to the port to come back to
the US and his men just had
extraordinary ability to recall things
that had happened to them it was so
vivid in their memories there's one
incident one of the things that just
terrified them the most was gas they all
said you know we can tell where the
bullets and the artillery are coming
from but we don't know where the gas is
coming from and one of the most
terrifying moments for them during the
war was when they had to do something
which the military called selective
unmasking
and this is when you got a gas attack
the warning would go out gasps gasps
gasps you'd hear it on the radios and
everybody knew this is it this is
serious potential gas attack everybody
would get in their chemical gear well
the military had little handheld
machines that troops would go out and
monitor the air to see if in fact there
really were gas or poisonous particles
and they would go out and if the
machines came back clean said there's no
chemical out there they would choose one
unit one tank to take off their masts to
see if in fact it was safe and if it was
safe then everybody else could take off
their masks well there were one of
lieutenant the ladies takes one night
that got picked to be the tank to unmask
and they were terrified they they didn't
want to take off their masks finally one
of the young men got up the courage
ripped off his mask and he gets all the
symptoms of gas poisoning and he feels
his chest constricting his nose is
running his arm is itching his eyes are
running he thinks he's gonna die he
looks up and he sees a fly buzzing
around the tank and realizes they know
he's not gonna die but in fact the air
is clean and everyone else can take off
their masks but these were very
terrifying moments for these young men
go back again to Bill Delaney's letters
his father Galen the merry McGorry they
were published in The Washington Post
did the word get back to Saudi Arabia
that these letters were published and
then have any negative impact on well as
it turned out the letters were published
the day before the ground war and so of
course everyone was then very absorbed
and what was going on in the ground war
and lieutenant Delaney was very
concerned when he heard that his father
had given these letters to the post
because he didn't know it and he didn't
know a story was being written about him
and he was very critical in some of the
letters of some of his commanders
especially the Commandant of the Marine
Corps at the time who was out great and
he was afraid that this would cause him
a lot of trouble in the end of course it
didn't why didn't it cause him any
trouble and do you think it should've
well I think it didn't cause him any
trouble because he portrayed the epitome
of what the Marine Corps wanted and a
jump on a young leader I mean here was a
guy who was just you know not some kid
who couldn't cut it anywhere else and
that's why he joined the military I'm
thinking just
wanted to go out and kill everything in
his path I mean this was a very
thoughtful intelligent young guy and it
was obvious from the letters that he
wrote and that were quoted in the post
and that are quoted and a woman at war
that he had this deep deep concern for
these men I mean at one point he
compares them he almost feels like
they're his children and he was very
concerned going into war would he lose
any of these men that he had trained and
that he was taking into battle he felt
personally responsible for their lives
so when you look at these minor details
of criticism in the overall picture it
was painted of this young commander it
was a perfect advertisement for the
marine corps where is he today he got a
job coming out working on the military
Commission on women in the military
because one of his commanders in fact
who I had introduced him to out there
General Tom droughty
who is public affairs director of the
Marine Corps came back and was a member
of the Commission and and your viewers
may recall this is a general who gave
some extraordinary quotes when the
Commission made its ruling he has a
daughter who now because the combat
exclusion laws on cockpits have been
listed will probably be one of the first
women fighter pilots in the Marine Corps
and he talked at length about the
profound effect of her career had on
changing his mind about the role women
should have in the military now he had
the nickname sage was his callsign
outdoing the Persian Gulf War because he
was considered one of the wiser generals
he had sort of the demeanor of a quiet
wizened professor and before he led his
headquarters unit into combat he pulled
out a copy of Henry v and read from from
it some of the passages of going into
war I mean some of the names of these
people it was almost as though you had
characters out of Hollywood one of my
favorites was General William Keyes who
was commander of the second Marine
Division and his nickname was pit bull
because he had pet pit bulls and he
carried a picture of one of them in his
wallet throughout the war there was one
general called Cyclops because he
had a glass eye the general who was in
charge of the first Marine Division
nickname was Cobra his men nicknamed him
that because he had this habit of
jerking his head like a cobra snake when
he would get mad at someone what are you
doing now
I am the south asia bureau chief of the
washington post my husband and i are a
spousal bureau we both work for the
washington post covering south asia and
we've had a few wars since the persian
gulf war that wars that are not getting
much notice now but are every bit as
brutal as the as the war in the former
yugoslavia in afghanistan where there's
still a bitter war going on in kashmir
in northern india where Indian forces
are involved in a war with their own
people a war between India and Pakistan
on the sea and glacier the highest war
in the world are fighting at 20,000 feet
so it's a region where there is a lot
going on and I've been able to use a lot
of the experience I had in the Persian
Gulf to carry over to this region of the
world where do you live I live in New
Delhi India where it's about a hundred
and twelve degrees today and the air
conditioning is not working it's a very
tough existence it's a very unlivable
city but the stories are extraordinary
and make up for it you mentioned in the
middle of the book at one point while
you're over there in the middle of this
warrior husband-to-be is skiing
somewhere right he was skiing in a condo
in Wyoming that that I had in fact
rented for our group of friends that
goes to eating every year he was
covering Virginia politics in Richmond
Virginia the Virginia General Assembly
throughout much of the war for the
Washington Post and was very frustrated
that here I was out covering the war and
he was covering politics but and then
after the war was over we had to
postpone our wedding because of the war
we had planned to get married but didn't
know how long the war was going to go on
and how long I was going to be in Saudi
Arabia and I ended up postponing it for
about six months
directly as a result of the war as many
of the troops out there had their lives
totally disrupted and had to postpone
plans sand the book that you were a
tomboy when you're gonna write which I
think led to my interest in the military
never had pictured myself as a military
reporter always the first woman to cover
the military for The Washington Post and
when I started covering the Pentagon in
1986 there were only two women reporters
covering four major organizations myself
and Melissa Healy for the Los Angeles
Times when I left there were three of us
and then brought it back down to two
suzanne Schaeffer was there along with
with The Associated Press along with
Melissa so it's still a press corps
that's very much male-dominated and
hopefully we'll see some changes in the
next few years because now there are
quite a few women military reporters
working for many of the trade journals
who chronicled the defense industry and
the military and I think over the next
few years we'll see many of those women
moving up into the daily news
organizations television and the major
media around the country where did you
grow up I grew up in Lake Charles
Louisiana which is in Southwest
Louisiana what was the family like um
well I got in the newspaper business
very early I started when I was 15 years
old my high school journalism teacher
got me a job on the Lake Charles
American press working on the weekends
for a dollar 60 an hour taking
obituaries and covering the Rotary Club
so I worked for them all through high
school and college which gave me a great
job this was a time of Watergate when
you know every kid who was interested in
journalism you know wanted to go work
for the Washington Post or some
newspaper and it was difficult you know
frequently I was writing stories about
some of my father's friends at the
courthouse who the newspaper painted as
crooks who was your partner
my father was Fred Moore who was worked
for the Department of Veterans Affairs
for his career my mother was Betty Moore
who was a registered nurse surgical
nurse emergency room nurse while I was
growing up and I lived on land that had
been in my family for five generations
on a bayou I mean it was almost your
stereotypical view of Louisiana weird
you'd a comment with a Georgetown
University majored in political science
and that's where I made my first contact
with the Washington Post I was a weekend
flunky for the Style section back then
in the more sexist days we recall that
girls and copy boys now we're called
news aides and begin really at the
lowest rungs and then left Washington at
the end of college and was hired by the
New Orleans times-picayune as their
education reporter and later was on
their investigative team and in 1981 Bob
Woodward was Metro editor of The
Washington Post and called and offered
me a job on the Metro staff where I
worked for five years before I joined
the national staff it was the first time
you thought you might want to be the
Pentagon correspondent I was on the
Virginia staff and covered quite a bit
of military in Norfolk whenever there
was a court-martial a major incident a
homecoming of a ship anything that the
military was was really involved in and
I hadn't really thought about it now at
the Washington Post if you're on Metro
where everybody wants to be as the
National staff that's the staff that has
the name and the prestige so we think
when we're on the Metro staff and it's
very difficult to get on the national
staff and about in 1986 one of the
Pentagon one of the two Pentagon jobs
came open and the national editor Bob
Kaiser came over and asked me if I'd
like to apply for the military job he
had seen some of the stories I had done
on the Virginia staff and liked them and
so I applied and what's the first time
that they had put a woman in this job
and even some of the editors at the post
wondered if that was a good idea not
that they think didn't think that I can
do the job they questioned whether these
old curmudgeon brass and the Pentagon
would take a woman seriously and in the
beginning they didn't it was very
difficult I had to go in you know three
times as prepared as a male reporter
would have to be to an interview because
you'd walk in and they would see you
especially if you had a young looking
face and say well what what can this
young thing know about the military so
you really had to go in and be extra
prepared was there any time where you
thought you were being mistreated
because you're a woman during the war
are during me not really because by that
point I had known many of these
commanders I had covered the military
for five years but I saw many
the women out there who I think were
mistreated looked down Don were treated
very condescendingly by the military
because they were women and they assumed
that they could they didn't know what
they were doing I had the advantage of
course at that point I had the name of
the Washington Post behind me so they're
going to treat you with a certain amount
of respect even if they may not like you
personally or they may not think a woman
should be in that job because it is the
Washington Post and they know it's read
in Washington you are going to be
treated with a certain amount of
credibility and respect any reaction
about the substance of this book from
any anybody any negative reaction not
much that I've seen of course the book
officially has only been out a few days
and people are just now reading it some
of the people who are in the book are
reading it for the first time so far
I've gotten very positive feedback from
them because I'm as many of the people
who were out there also had the same
impression that nobody really saw the
true picture of what they did out there
and there was this view that everything
worked perfectly and there were chaos
there were equipments that the military
had spent billions of dollars on that
just flat didn't work out there and one
of the lessons learned that I that I
talked about in the book in the course
of my research I got quite a few secret
reports that were written by the
military about the performance of the
equipment and the troops during the war
some of which still have not been
released and one of the recommendations
in one of the Marine Corps reports was
that perhaps the military has gone too
far and spending money on tanks that
shoot further and can do more that now
they've exceeded the capability of the
men and women out there using them in
this case the troops would look through
their fancy night-vision scopes on the
tank and if they saw a vehicle out on
the horizon they all he could see was a
bot they didn't know whether it was an
Iraqi blob or an American blob and quite
a few of the troops and the young men
and women that I interviewed were very
happy to see some of these things
brought out that they were afraid would
be lost and that people would just have
this view of war is very clean and very
easy
is there anything you didn't put in the
book because of the sensitivity of it
all
no not really there were things I didn't
put in the book for lack of space it's
like writing a news story you gather far
more material than you can ever possibly
put in the book and it's heart-wrenching
as you you go through the process to
have to throw away entire chapters but I
feel like I didn't pull any punches I
painted a picture of Schwarzkopf that
were I to talk to him I suspect he may
not like too well and paint a picture of
some of the problems on the battlefield
another thing that I talk about fairly
extensively in the book is the women who
were out in the Persian Gulf War
and I think they exploded quite a few of
the myths that the men and the Pentagon
had that when it came to wartime women
wouldn't be able to do their jobs the
men wouldn't be able to do their jobs
because they would be so worried about
the women being killed or shot and time
and time again you saw women just I
never had a commander say that a woman
didn't do her job fully as she was
supposed to the other thing that's
exposed was the fallacy of the combat
exclusion laws the US military and
Congress have law saying women will not
serve in combat there were women in
combat all over the battlefield out
there there were women closer to the
front lines than their husbands were now
in the end some of this was very
frustrating to the women especially for
instance in boomers command posts
because he took me forward into combat
and wouldn't take any of the women
because technically they weren't
supposed to be going into the front
lines and so here they have trained and
trained for these jobs and weren't
allowed to do them and yet here came
along this woman reporter and she can
charge into battle with the senior
general and it was very frustrating for
some of them complete the sentence Molly
Moore was the first woman in history to
do what probably to spend the war at the
side of a commanding general who was
actually leading his troops into battle
and as I remember six people were
offered this opportunity and you're the
only one that went right the other five
turned it down saying that they wanted
to be on the combat pools that were with
frontline troops and in the end we saw
more combat than any of those reporters
did because we were out there right in
the middle of the battle in fact at one
point general boomers men are screaming
adding on the radio that he's
ahead of his ground troops and the
Iraqis are just right over the horizon
and had to tell him to pull his convoy
back when you were out there in the
middle of I guess at one point you were
in Kuwait right for a go out most of the
time we were in Kuwait because we
crossed over the border and we're
actually in Kuwait proper for most of
the ground war did you file a story from
the battle zone back to the Washington
Post that ended up getting published
before the whole thing was over after
the first day of the war I filed during
the course of the day stories from
rumors rear command post which was right
on the Kuwait border but I never got a
story out from Kuwait while we were on
the ground during the ground war
essentially went the three days the the
main part of the ground war and could
not get a story out finally the last day
of the war when the city had been
liberated and I came up to boomer and
said look I'm gonna be fired if I don't
get a story out of this I mean the post
has sent me out here to cover the war we
haven't been able to get a story out and
he was flying back to his rear command
post right on the border and took me in
one of his helicopters back with him and
that's the first story I've had filed in
three days go back to what we talked
about the very first chapter you're out
there with the general you stay you
spent what one night in the generals
tent - all right how do you write things
that you hear that you know the general
will not like gotta feed it he has to
look at it first right how do you do
that
you just do it and you take your chances
that he will or won't take things out
take anything out ever the first day he
took a couple of things out he took out
an account of a battle that I described
that he thought I described the Marines
as getting hit too hard in this battle
and I disagreed with him he had the
right to take anything out yeah
absolutely right to take whatever he
wanted out now I could protest but the
problem is the protest would take two or
three days to go through the Pentagon
censoring process and so you would
defeat yourself so as a reporter you
would take some of the stuff out just so
you could get the vast bulk of your
material out and the first day everyone
was understandably nervous and as it
turned out the account of the battle
that he thought I had
ADEs sound too difficult for the Marine
Corps was even worse than I had
described it the problem was he hadn't
been able to communicate with his
commander to find out all the details of
it at that point all right what did you
have with you beside your tape recorder
no cat a notebook no what do you have a
computer with I had a computer right
when in August when we first went out
there I dutifully went out and bought a
manual typewriter figuring that's what
we'd have to use well this being
somewhat of a high-tech military I in
the end I could take my Toshiba laptop
write my story on it take the disc out
end it out to a computer whiz at the
military communications tent and he
would send it through the military
message traffic by satellite back to a
rear base in Dhahran where then the
story would be distributed to all of the
other reporters who were there what's
the fastest you ever got a story from
your computer back to the Washington
Post oh well I would never consider
anything I did out there fast I mean
we're talking sometimes a matter of days
the fastest was probably 12 hours and
besides your computer and your tape
recorder and your notebooks what did you
carry with you
how'd you dress well you couldn't carry
much because you had to be able to carry
everything I basically dressed we didn't
dress in uniforms although I did have a
military parka that I wore because it
was so cold you I was in contrast to
what some people may think about the
desert it was bitterly cold during the
ground war part of this war and you are
a flak jacket because they were shrapnel
going off we would drive through burning
tank fields where the Americans had just
destroyed all the tanks and artillery
and as she went by the ammunition and
those tanks would cook off just sending
in a huge burst of ammo into the air we
were wearing a helmet you were wearing
layers of sweaters I was wearing police
line boots because it was so cold to
wear in the sand and a knee rucksack I
basically carriage didn't have sex that
you were carrying just the necessities
you needed for life you know a basic
toothbrush one change of clothes
there was no way to take showers so one
of the most popular items out there were
baby wipes the baby wipe business did a
booming business everyone from general
boomer down to lieutenant Delaney
carried big packages of baby wipes with
him because you had water was so limited
it couldn't be used for showers what's
the longest you went without a shower
long as I went without a shower was
about seven days what you're feeling
pretty grungy at the end of that what's
the longest the troops went without sure
lieutenant bill Delaney and his men went
as long as three months without a shower
they went so long without a shower that
when they finally got one after the war
they said it hurt their skin when you
think back about it having been there
what do you know that we don't having
never been in the front lines of a war
what are the kinds of things that
surprised you the most I put a lot of
them in the book a woman at war so that
people could be right there on the
frontlines and feel some of this but
there's no way to calculate the emotions
and the anxiety level of going into a
situation like this I mean
retrospectively everybody says oh this
was a cakewalk you know there were
relatively few casualties compared to
the number of troops that were out there
but even though there were so few
casualties there was just all the trauma
of any war and the trauma of these young
men for the first time looking through
their scopes and seeing a human being
that they're gonna kill and coming to
grips with that many of them who had
bragged their entire careers you know
all I wanted to do is put the crosshairs
on a target once they got out there and
did it they found it very terrifying and
gut-wrenching to have to make those
kinds of decisions the commander's you
start to see these very polished guys
standing up at the press conferences but
to get inside their heads and see the
anguish that went into every decision
they made
Schwarzkopf and his press conferences
painted the war is very well
orchestrated and you had the maps with
the sweeping arrows and it made it look
like you know everything was just
carefully planned well many of the plans
fell apart on the battlefield because it
was moving so quickly troops were
getting tangled up with each other the
Arab forces couldn't keep up with the
American forces and we're falling behind
and there were gaps in the lines of the
troops the army as it turned out had to
start its attack
20 hours before it was scheduled because
the Marines were moving so quickly
through Kuwait all right how about this
I know you write about this but the
simple thing of female latrine how did
you deal with that you're the only woman
I'm what among 38 men 38 men and as I
said before this is a flat desert
there's not even a bush out there to
hide behind so that was probably the
single most difficult thing of being a
woman out there and you're out there
there's no place to hide there's no
privacy but for the men are the women
but for me being a woman it was of
course a little more difficult sorry
basically after wait till night and when
it fortunately it was so dark from the
oil wells and you know you were wearing
this long parka that you could kind of
go off in a corner the campsite but even
that was difficult because we were
camped in the middle of a minefield and
the troops had pulled the the vehicles
in a circle around us essentially and
didn't want anybody stepping outside
that circle to go to the bathroom or do
anything else so it made it very
difficulty difficult to find you know
even a moment of privacy anywhere your
own family
afraid well my own family and and they
learned from reading the book much that
they didn't know at the time they
learned how much my husband and I had
lied to them about what I was doing I
kept sending back the messages oh I'm
sitting in a nice cushy hotel there in
Tehran everything is perfectly safe of
course when the Scud started landing I
kind of blew that theory and it wasn't
in fact so safe but they didn't know at
the time that I was out on the front
lines and in combat and in the war they
didn't find out until after the war at
which point I think they were a little
grateful that they didn't know because
they would have probably worried
themselves to death at what moment were
you afraid the whole time I mean the
most physical your knees ever not gonna
probably there were two points that that
were the most frightening in the first
were the Scud attacks
general Schwarzkopf described the sky as
a weapon of terror he said you know it's
not accurate it's nothing we really have
to worry about what he was right it had
us terrorized the hotel that we were
living in which none of us could write
or say on the air at the time and I'm
sure everybody remembers the television
reporters doing their stand ups on this
hotel with the blue domes and the
crowd that hotel was right in the middle
of the biggest airfield in Saudi Arabia
where the Americans had more air power
than any other place in Saudi Arabia and
the Iraqis knew exactly where it was and
it was a prime target for most of the
Scud attacks in eastern Saudi Arabia
where directly directly at this Airport
so we knew that there was a very good
probability that at least one of these
scuds could land in the near vicinity or
land on our hotel
now there were Patriot missiles out
there which gave us a false sense of
security at the time because we didn't
know at the time how many of the scuds
the Patriots were missing when they were
firing and the Patriots you could see
from our hotel and you could hear the
booms go off so it was very terrifying
to be sitting down in that basement and
the first few nights of the scout
attacks I didn't have a chemical suit
the Washington Post had ordered the
chemical suits from British Aerospace
and they were recalled because of an
effect so here are all my colleagues
pulling on their chemical suits and I'm
sitting here feeling naked sitting in a
raincoat which would have done me
absolutely no good so that was the the
first most terrifying moment the second
was when I was out on a combat pool
about two weeks before the ground war
began I was with the logistics supply
unit and they were going to go out into
the battle and resupply and refill the
troops and come back to their command
post and then go back out to another
battle setting which was a perfect place
for a reporter to be you'd see lots of
different parts of the battlefield
about the third day I was out there the
public affairs escort who is with us
went to a staff meeting and came back to
the tent and told us his face was just
ashen and he said I've just been giving
a briefing on the plan for what our unit
is going to do that you're going to
accompany in the battle and they've told
us to expect 50% casualties including
the reporters so I want to give you this
opportunity to call your editors and
tell them that they should probably have
a backup reporter in case something
happens to you and that was a moment
when your knees started knocking and you
said you know do I really want to go
through with this it's a bit out of
sequence but we are running out of time
please tell the f-15 story this happened
the first week of the invasion when I
was on the plane with Secretary of
Defense Dick Cheney and he was scurrying
around as I said trying to get air bases
in these countries that did not want
Americans on their soil and one of the
places was Qatar Qatar and it was the
last stop of this grueling grueling we
did something like six countries in 15
hour in in in 24 hours we were just all
exhausted and this was one of the the
first times that so when this high
ranking it had ever been in the country
and pete williams who was then the
spokesman i'm sure everybody remembers
seeing on TV every day at the time
wanted to make sure the TV footage film
got out he called the pentagon the
consulate the American consulate there
were supposed to have had a satellite
dish up and they didn't to get the film
out so he called the Pentagon and said
what's the fastest plane you can get me
I've got to get this film out we've got
to get it to Cairo or another location
where it can be satellited back and they
said in f-15 he said send it so they
sent an f15 the local American diplomats
there went ballistic they screamed in
and said you've got to be crazy here we
are trying to get fighter jets placed on
their soil they don't want it and you're
calling in a fighter jet to bring some
TV film out of here get something else
so he called the Pentagon and got ac-12
which is essentially a little Learjet
but meanwhile the local military in this
Arab country heard that they were gonna
see their first f15 they got out the
honor band they had the honor card and
they were all out there waiting for this
pilot to arrive they were gonna give him
you know the great celebration and lo
and behold this little clunky c12
arrives and they were just horrendously
disappointed but as it turns out it
wouldn't have foiled any of the
diplomatic efforts these guys were just
absolutely ecstatic that they were going
to get to see one of these planes and in
the end the country did allow American
aircraft to be put on their bases your
conclusion about the American
involvement in this war it's very it's
very frustrating for me to have seen
this involvement and see now but we're
not getting involved in it was very
clear to me at the time and and I feel
even more strongly now we got involved
in this war because of oil granted it
was
it was a good cost to try to free Kuwait
it said I was there when the city was
liberated and the outpouring of emotion
of these people who had been hiding for
days and their basements terrified for
you know six or seven months was
extraordinary but there the situation
going on in Bosnia situation in
Afghanistan and Kashmir in India just as
horrendous atrocities and the West is
really turning a deaf ear to it so the
spirit this war was very much a
political war in my estimation you're in
India now you go to the front frequently
I've go into Afghanistan Kabul is still
being shelled every day much like
Sarajevo most much of the city has fled
are been killed in Kashmir this frequent
fighting we frequently my husband and I
both go into war situations in South
Asia and in many ways it's much more
dangerous than the persian gulf war
because in these wars you frequently
don't know who the enemy is are you
getting used to being close to gunfire
no I think in fact I've gotten less
courageous with each war situation that
I go into because you realize the risk
you're taking and the danger involved
and the Persian Gulf War much of the
time you were so caught up in being out
there you were working so hard to do
your job that was so difficult to get
stories out that you didn't think about
the danger until it was over you know at
the end of the ground war I didn't think
about the danger the entire very little
of the four days because there was so
much going on around me that I was
trying to absorb but after it was over I
thought you know my god what have I just
done here how long you gonna spend in
India it's a three-year tour and we have
two more years left then what do you
want to do I will probably do a book on
South Asia and then hopefully move on to
another foreign posting and this book
what what what at what point will you
say this has been a success I've been
worth it
it was worth it for me just getting it
down on paper and getting a view of the
war out that I think most people didn't
see and I've been overwhelmed by the
positive response the reviews the
reaction to the book one of the best
reactions that I got was from a young
marine who had read it and I called the
office where he was working and he
picked up and he says gee ma'am I just
read your book and it's awesome
I thought if some young macho marine
would say that about it that's about one
of the best reviews I could get on the
back Bob Woodward dan Rather George
Wilson they used to be a report at the
post and used to cover the Pentagon and
John layman former Secretary of the Navy
endorsed this book was that your idea I
was most of my publishers ideas they
came up with the people to contact and I
was very excited by the response in fact
that they got from the people and
they're really strong positive comments
that they made on the book
have you watched only television of this
war would you've had the clear and
honest picture oh absolutely not you
would have gotten a very distorted
picture you would have gotten a
distorted picture even reading the
newspaper stories in my own paper simply
because we couldn't get much of the
information out in a timely manner and
by the time we could get it out the
story had moved on it had moved on to
the Kurds it had moved on to the
diplomatic questions and nobody cared
what went on in the ground war because
it was perceived as this great victory
with very few casualties so why do we
care very much about the details by the
way who's the boss out there in India
you or your husband
I'm the bureau chief my husband is the
correspondent which some of the South
Asian chauvinists have a hard time
taking on that note thank you very much
Molly more this is what the book looks
like woman at war account of choice in
the Gulf thank you for joining us it's
been a pleasure